the whole reason i started spacex was
actually to try to increase nasa's
budget
um or at least the way i got interested
in space was uh i tried to figure out
why we had not gone to mars and and i
thought well
uh maybe it's we need to reignite public
excitement in mars so i initially
started off
with the idea of doing this like
philanthropic mission to send a small
greenhouse to mars
to get the public excited about
sending life to mars yeah and if we got
the public excited then they would tell
their representatives in congress uh and
to increase nasa's budget
that was the goal but it was no action
it was meant to be a philanthropic thing
yeah um and then i tried i tried to buy
some icbms in russia to do this and
ultimately came to conclusion that and
that there's actually plenty of will
to to go beyond earth but there needs to
be a way like essentially nasa needs to
have um you know more affordable rockets
that we need to increase the pace of
innovation uh in space and so if we can
give nasa another horse in the stable um
that that is moving faster
and cost less and
more innovative then that would be a way
to accelerate progress in space so
i i love nasa and always have and always
will want to be happy build a life not
just a business hey it's evan carmichael
and this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the seven
best lessons from super successful
entrepreneurs
enjoy
lesson number two be vision driven with
jack ma you made some really important
acquisitions along the way
uh where do you see alibaba going
over the next 10 years
you're already in
hollywood yep
uh you're in
the icl
in the cloud
i mean you're doing things that beyond
the transactional
basis of your business
we doing business we go from
marketplaces to payment to logistics and
to cloud not because we think there are
money there
we believe if when we build the
marketplaces if we don't have the
payment solutions
our customers cannot do it transactions
when we have the payment we know if we
don't have logistics they cannot we
cannot they cannot finish the
transactions and when we have a lot of
transactions we say if we don't have
cloud computing the cost of i.t for our
customers too expensive so we do all
these things not because we think
there's money there because we know if
we don't do that our customers cannot
finish
their job their work our amazing is
helping doing business easier so our
company
must be
amazing and vision driven why we are on
the hollywood i mean the entertainment
because we think
10 20 years later
we have to know one thing the world and
everybody no matter how rich you are
you want to be or how successful you are
or how successful you are the most
important thing is happy and healthy
which called a double age strategy
healthy and happy yeah so now in this
next 10 years we are very confident
about everything we are doing
our marketplace's e-commerce will keep
on growing our our financing will keep
on growing logistics people are growing
a cloud computer will come growing and
then when we have that much money how
can we help the small business when they
do business their business are happier
and healthier
so that's why so we do not think we are
a company we think we are economy lesson
number three focus on the customer
experience with jeff bezos there's one
reason
we have done better than most of our
peers
in the internet space you know over the
last six years it is because we have
focused like a laser on customer
experience and that really does matter
i think in any business it certainly
matters online
where word of mouth is so very very
powerful you know if you make a customer
unhappy they won't tell five friends
they'll tell 5 000 friends so we are at
a point now
where we have all the things we need to
build an important and lasting company
and if we don't it will be shame on us
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there lesson number four stand for
something with oprah winfrey here are
variations on a few grand themes
beginning with this pick a problem
any problem the list is long here just a
few
that are at the top of my list there's
gun violence and there's climate change
and systemic racism
economic inequality media bias
the homeless need opportunity the
addicted need treatment the dreamers
need protection the prison system needs
reforming the lgbt community
the
lgbtq community needs acceptance
the social safety net needs saving and
the misogyny needs to stop
[Applause]
needs to stop
but you can't fix everything
and you can't save every soul but what
can you do
here and now
i believe you have to declare war on one
of our most dangerous enemies and that
is cynicism because when that little
creature sinks in its hooks into you
it'll cloud your clarity it'll
compromise your integrity it'll lower
your standards it'll choke your empathy
and sooner or later
cynicism shatters your
faith when you hear yourself saying oh
it doesn't matter what one person says
oh well so what it's not going to make
any difference what i do who cares when
you hear yourself saying that know that
you're on a collision course for our
culture
and i understand how it's so easy to
become
disillusioned so tempting to allow
apathy to set in because anxiety is
being broadcast on 157 channels 24 hours
a day all night long
and everybody i know is feeling it
but these times
these times are here to let us know
that we need to take a stand
for our right to have hope
and we need to take a stand with every
ounce of wit and courage we can muster
the question is what are you willing to
stand for
that question
is going to follow you throughout your
life and here's how you answer it
you put your honor
where your mouth is
put your honor
where your mouth is
when you give your word keep it show up
do the work
get your hands dirty and then you'll
begin to draw strength from the
understanding the true knowing that
history
is still
being written
you're writing it every day
the will's still in spin and what you do
or what you don't do will be a part of
it lesson number five be a good
delegator with richard branson my
dyslexia really helped me become a
really good delegator and i think
that's been one of my great strengths so
i've had to find brilliant people around
me
um over the last 50 years and all the
different ventures we've done
and
be willing to give them a lot of freedom
um freedom to
do good things and for them to make
mistakes and um
and by and large it's worked and and
that's freed me up to
you know worry about
yeah um the next hyperloop one well the
the next projects but also just to look
after oneself you know and look up you
know spend time with one's family um and
and be ready to troubleshoot when
something goes wrong so
um so not to get bogged down by the
minute i and
um and i think the best bit of advice i
can give anybody any entrepreneur is
you know find somebody better than
yourself
you know give them the freedom to you
know step into your shoes and then you
know clear the decks yourself and all
those things that you were doing hand
over to them
and then you'll you'll find very quickly
you know that the desk will be full up
with new ideas which you can then hand
over again and you can keep doing that
and
and
and then you can become
you know a
serial philanthropist as well as a
serial entrepreneur lesson number six
always keep learning with mark cuban how
often do you do you uh educate yourself
a day like is it like an hour like
every day every minute that everything i
do is about learning more because that's
the only way i can kick your ass you
know it's not i'm not gonna out athletic
you right
it's not about my basketball iq it's
about my my business iq right in
technology and business
and everything's always changing if you
know five years ago if someone would ask
me about artificial intelligence i
wouldn't know right yet ai is the most
important part of technology and really
business going forward so if i'm going
to be an effective investor an effective
mentor an effective you know um operator
of businesses
you know even with the maps i got to
understand ai because you know like with
the mavericks when you know when you
talk about analytics
it's changed so dramatically even over
the last five years going from you know
different types of things per and you
know advanced rpm and all these
different metrics for basketball to how
do you implement artificial intelligence
and pose estimation and computer vision
and how do you understand all that stuff
to make the right decisions for the maps
and so if i want to be in a position to
make those decisions and not just ask
somebody else to do it i got to learn
learner and so i put in hours i do
tutorials i take little online classes
and it doesn't make me an expert it's
not like i'm gonna say that you know i
could get a job if i needed to running
ai or running um tech for a big company
i couldn't but i understand all the
concepts and understand the issues and
how to apply them to business so if
you're going to be good at anything you
got to stay ahead of the game and
business is the ultimate sport you know
i i used to say it to dirk and i always
say to luca you know it's like dude you
know you play 48 minutes you know a 48
minute game you practice a couple hours
you go home and you relax and you play
you know you play call of duty you know
business is 24x7 i'm going every day
because there's some 16 year old kid out
there trying to kick my ass in one of my
companies and it ain't going to happen
right and so i'm that competitive and
i'm that you know i work that hard at
learning to try to stay ahead of the
game and lesson number seven the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is build relationships with grant
cardone talk about family life because
there's a business
family life family family
yeah and there's a bit of a similarity
between yourself i mean a sense i've got
two girls similar age hold your kids
seven or ten so mine's four and eight
yeah okay and um my wife um
you know i met a in a similar kind of
way but how important is it you know how
important is it really important like
you want you know no matter what you're
doing all day long on the battlefield
you want to come home and
have yeah you know have
mutual agreement on what's going on yeah
you know i was
there was four of us yesterday we were
at starbucks or something
all four of us on instagram i'm like
what is happening
yeah we're not even together anymore
yeah four people
and everybody's looking at their own
different thing right yeah i said
something nobody heard me i'm like
what's going on you don't want to be
alone no nobody wants to be alone yeah
like like i mean maybe the alone person
wants to be alone but
success is better when you have somebody
to share with yeah you know when you're
successful and you have nobody to talk
to
hey i did this deal today
or you have or or worse
i don't know if this is worse or not but
it's similar is you don't have anybody
to tell yeah or you tell them
and they're like we don't need all that
that that that's another form of just
isolation yeah so you know i i want to
be on the i want to be
i want to have a team man i want to have
a team that's excited about what we're
doing and what we're accomplishing
um so then having family and having
people that want to be on the same and
it's challenging too
having other people is challenging
when god created this planet
he created up several species
now if you're an atheist it's okay call
it the force let me just say god for now
so i don't have to say god the forest
god the forest let's just say god right
now god creates a planet earth and first
of all he creates which a lot of people
in different organizations want a
perfect social economic world where
everything is free don't worry about a
thing you're taken care of
there's no extra imagination necessary
it's all gonna be given to you so he
creates the oyster he says oyster i'm
giving you a free house to live in i'm
calling it a shell i'm gonna put at the
bottom of the ocean
to protect you from your enemies
you have food clothing all the food you
want protection
everything you want the perfectly taken
care of while you're in your measly
little life as an oyster but you're not
going to go anywhere
you stay there at the bottom of the
ocean but you totally got your free food
free clothing free everything you want
then god created something called the
eagle eagle whole different species
eagle
you want a house you go out and build it
take the top of a mountain take the top
of a tree go out and build your own
house you want some food to eat no
problem go out there and find it eagle
and the eagle flies through miles in the
winter time of rain sleet snow and wind
just to feed its young
did you know the eagle fails 95
of the time a total failure it's so big
and cumbersome that when it comes upon
its prey they're wild they shoot off in
a different direction and it misses
five percent of the time it succeeds and
what does succeed to do it succeeded to
be the strongest bird in the sky
the only one that we know of anywhere in
the world that could fly into the
thermals of a hurricane and ride them to
have fun now the eagle unlike the oyster
can go anywhere it wants anywhere it
wants yeah gambles it does this on its
own but it goes wherever it wants
now that eagle and not the oyster is the
emblem of america
and also on the flag of many many
countries you wouldn't be in this room
right now if you weren't eagles don't
only imagine start doing it thank you
peace love and happiness to all of you
thank you very much thank you
all the things in the world that you
could say are like the secrets that
being positive is one of the
main things that people need to do how
did you happen on that in life
whether it's personal or people around
me when you see people that are positive
that look at something good and
something bad that took place
they move along in life faster they're
better and people want to be around
these people i mean too often people
gossip the one gossip person wants to be
around the other person that gossips
but they don't realize
when you gossip you're saying something
you heard about somebody else you're
telling everybody what if part of it was
wrong you're gonna go out and tell every
person you told this oh i'm sorry it was
wrong tell everybody you told it's not
gonna happen so it's things to learn
about don't gossip don't belittle people
if you don't have to god please don't
try and look at the positive angle what
good could come out of something and
that positiveness is going to make you
live longer
happier and wake up in the morning happy
not oh my god i gotta go to work i can't
wait till i get home i want to retire
because people were not positive they
were not happy and what happens if they
retire they hate their job they retire
three or four years later they're dead
because they have nothing to do that
positive attitude be around positive
people encourage positiveness if you
find yourself walking around just
complaining all the time around people
that complain a lot man move or just try
and do something different change your
life being positive and a positive
attitude is find something positive and
something bad
makes you look for solutions when i was
down and out okay oh pop bottles let's
get the pop bottles cash them in our
grid entrepreneurs
should not have a money if you have a
money in mind this ice is u.s dollars
this is i'm b and you're talking like
english pounds nobody
will work with like
if you have a good dream
if you have a plan to making things
making progress things were happening
and i changed my mind to this morning
just
half an hour there i would do more
things
in africa and the only thing i want to
do is not to sell
products here
and i will enable you to sell your
dreams all over the world in africa
supporting entrepreneurs is always my my
dream because i know
how tough it is to be an entrepreneur
it is difficult
i never cry i said i only make my
competitors cry
because if i cry
i probably die a hundred times
because we have to encourage our team
and i say
making sure that we
that we can survive tomorrow as i said
before i answer a question
i want to say this is my belief
and this is what i tell every day to
myself today is difficult
tomorrow is much more difficult but the
day of tomorrow is beautiful most people
die tomorrow evening
even today as my size
for our company's size
i still believe
today is very difficult i have more
problems
than anybody here can imagine
you say ah now you are big you make
billions of dollars
every you know quarter
i have much more problems than you have
when i worked for other companies some
of them not to mention any names
were so bad
they would treat people the old way i'm
the boss here's what you're gonna do
because i'm the boss right or there were
times for example where maybe had a
dollar for lunch you can't get a lot for
a dollar so i just knew that that's how
i was and if i had a company that i had
control of by gosh everyone's going to
be treated the way i wanted to be
treated so the minute we could afford it
everyone had free lunch whether you had
money or not you have free lunch we pay
for it for you carpool will pay for that
so we started doing things for people
that i wish happened to me
maybe that's part of fate maybe because
a lot of things along the way weren't so
good that as things started getting good
it was so easy for me to share with our
people so easy to do that people
sometimes don't save money
as soon as we possibly could afford it
we started profit sharing we're at the
end of every year and we'll take that
profit sharing and put in a retirement
fund for you it's yours it's yours if
you're here so many years it goes with
you no matter where you go but it's
yours that's your money
that's really incredible and how much do
you think that that sort of golden rule
approach has fed into your
ridiculously low turnover rate which is
literally
almost unprecedented i mean that's crazy
i try and treat people exactly the way
they'd want to be treated exactly or the
way i would have wanted to be treated
i'm happy with my people i realized my
people are the company if my people go
my god the company goes people are your
company and they take care of the
customer the customer is always right no
matter what so what do we do so the
customers happier if somebody's unhappy
would try and discover why
and because you treat people this way
and we love them you walk in our
companies love if you go to the front
desk here in century city this girl just
has the biggest smile saying hi welcome
to john paul mitchell system she loves
what she does
our big problem is
we don't have turnover we have so many
people out of work for us and the thing
is you got to wait for somebody to die
now as we grow we'll add one or two on
obviously at a time sure and we're
pretty big now because we're in 96
countries it's how you take care of
people anywhere in the world you don't
blossom around you including what you're
doing and my question to you is if you
suddenly found yourself to be say a
sophomore in college at harvard what do
you think you would study and how do you
think you'd spend your time engaging
activities
well the thing that you're likely to be
world class at
is whatever you obsessed over from say
age 12 to 18.
you know in my case it was writing
software
uh where i would think i was good and
then i would meet somebody who would
tell me i wasn't and i would look at
their code and i went through four sort
of comeuppances of oh that's what a
really good programmer looks like and
part of the reason i worship digital
equipment was eventually it was a couple
of their very best programmers who came
and shared with me how they thought
about how they did thing and i had
studied their code and uh
and that and there
there were several people who were so
key to my doing that so today
i would go into
you know software which today that means
going into artificial intelligence uh
you know computers still can't read
they
they cannot take a book of information
and say pass an ap test on that book and
that's a solvable problem but it's a
knowledge representation problem
and
you know i've always wanted to solve
that problem uh i'm jealous that maybe
one of you gets
to work on that i'm you know unlikely to
go back and be
hands on in that in that way but it's
the juiciest problem ever i've thought
about it for a long time uh so i would
go into ai yeah if you want to have
impact
uh
usually delegation's important
although you know individual
contributors in terms of inventing a
drug or a new approach to things
that's phenomenal so when microsoft
first got started i wrote most the code
and everybody else's code i read and
kind of rewrote uh and
that got us up to 10 people and then i
had to say to myself okay we're going to
ship code that i didn't edit uh and that
was hard for me uh but you know i kind
of got over that then i still said okay
i'm going to interview everyone and i'm
going to at least look at samples of
their code well that got us up to about
40 people
and that was at a point where
i had sold way more software than we
could write
because everybody was so impressed and i
thought well i need
to keep enough collect enough money
to you know keep hiring all these people
but uh the demand was so high that you
know we were actually falling behind
that's when i hired steve
and steve figured out
a
uh
how to control what promises i made to
people uh and b how to hire lots of
people and good really good people and
create organizations and teams so i
delegated to steve that and he was
constantly saying to me okay
we're going to hire programmers that
you've never met and i'd say no or not
and then
he would show me numerically that the
constraint wasn't going to work uh you
know so uh then i said okay then i would
you know know all the managers of the
people and so over time
uh and of course
you know i could say the quality per
person was falling monotonically
uh
according to me uh
but you know large problems
uh if you want to you know write the
most popular
office productivity software that one
person absolutely can't do that you can
write pretty code so everyone has to
decide
what scale of organization they want to
work in eventually
you know my role was very much as a
leader and a reviewer of managers but
the top people and i hired some super
experienced people
i would make sure they were pursuing a
common vision and they were well
coordinated but in terms of a lot of
management stuff they were way better
than i was now i had to have the
framework
to know what mix of skills that we
needed and you know when they were
working well enough together but a lot
of
uh
you know my
value-added was picking
say to do graphics user interface or to
do an integrated office uh type thing or
to go global and not use agents to have
microsoft be present all over the world
and
so yeah picking what you're good at and
how you find the other people
uh to fill in those things that's super
important and most founders don't aren't
able to scale that up and kind of give
up
the hands-on things that they used to
get a lot of
uh pleasure and comfort from i think
you know you can over
worship and mythologize the idea of
working extremely hard
for my particular makeup
i mean it really is true that i didn't
believe in weekends i didn't believe in
vacations i mean you know i knew
everybody's license plate so i could
tell you over the last month when their
car had come and gone from the parking
lot is so i don't recommend it eh
i don't think most people would enjoy it
uh once i got into my 30s i could hardly
even imagine how i had done that uh
because by then some natural behavior
kicked in and i loved weekends and uh
you know my girlfriend liked vacations
and that turned out to be kind of a neat
thing
uh now i take lots of vacations
my 20 year old self is so disgusted with
my uh current uh
uh itself you know i i was sure i would
never do anything riding coach you know
now i have a plane so it's it's
very much counter revelations have taken
place at high speed
but yes it is nice
if during those first several years
if you have a team that's chosen to be
pretty
maniacal about the company and how far
that goes you know should have a mutual
understanding so you're not uh one
person expecting one thing another
person to expect another thing
and you'll have individuals who who have
you know health or relatives or things
that are distracted but yes i
have a fairly hardcore view
that there should be a very large
uh
sacrifice made during those those early
years you want to have impact uh
usually delegations important um
although you know individual
contributors in terms of inventing a
drug or a new approach to things
that's phenomenal so when microsoft
first got started i wrote most the code
and everybody else's code i read and
kind of rewrote uh
and
that got us up to 10 people and then i
had to say to myself okay we're going to
ship code that i didn't edit
uh
and that was hard for me uh but you know
i kind of got over that then i still
said okay i'm gonna interview everyone
and i'm gonna at least look at samples
of their code well that got us up to
about 40 people
and that was at a point where
i had sold way more software than we
could write uh because everybody was so
impressed and i thought well i need to
keep enough collect enough money
to you know keep hiring all these people
but uh the demand was so high that you
know we were actually falling behind
that's when i hired steve
and steve figured out a
uh how to control what promises i made
to people uh and b how to hire lots of
people and good really good people and
create organizations and teams so i
delegated to steve that and he was
constantly saying to me okay we're gonna
hire programmers that you've never met
and i'd say no or not and then
he would show me numerically that the
constraint wasn't going to work uh you
know so uh then i said okay then i would
you know
know all the managers of the people and
so over time uh and of course
you know i could say the quality per
person was falling monotonically
uh
uh
according to me
uh
but you know large problems
uh if you want to you know write the
most popular
office productivity software that one
person absolutely can't do that you can
write pretty code so everyone has to
decide what scale of organization they
want to work in eventually
you know my role was very much as a
leader and a reviewer of managers but
the top people and i hired some super
experienced people
i would make sure they were pursuing a
common vision and they were well
coordinated but in terms of a lot of
management stuff they were way better
than i was now i had to have the
framework to know what mix of skills
that we needed and you know when they
were working well enough together but a
lot of uh
you know my
value-added was picking
say to do graphics user interface or to
do an integrated office uh type thing or
to go global and not use agents to have
microsoft be present all over the world
and
so yeah picking what you're good at and
how you find the other people uh to fill
in those things that's super important
and most founders don't aren't able to
scale that up and kind of give up
the hands-on things that they used to
get a lot of
uh pleasure and comfort from i think
there's a problem in in western europe
where um where failure is
it's it's too impossible to fail once
you fail you can never you can never
start over i think there's a there's an
opposite version of this in california
where i think sometimes people
are a little bit too facile about
failure because i i think it actually is
always incredibly damaging to people
and if you work really hard at something
and it doesn't work um
that's you know that's that's going to
be
psychologically damaging you know people
have less confidence you all sorts of
reasons why why that tends to be uh that
tends to be quite bad i think that um i
think when people
i don't think there's that much you
learn from failure by the way because um
it's it's typically over determined it's
like why is technology slowing down why
did you fail it's typically five
separate reasons you worked with the
wrong people the idea was bad the timing
was wrong it wasn't a monopoly the
product didn't work
and okay next time i'm working with
different people you figure out one out
of the five things you're likely to fail
fail again uh so i think i think uh
failure is not something one can learn
very much from i think that's sort of a
myth that i i would challenge
um but what i think what i think you
should do when you when something so
anyway we we got this company just about
ready to launch
and uh we're looking at it one and
looking at this little tiny fulfillment
center we were here by then in this
building we had a basement fulfillment
center to call it a fulfillment center
was very grand there's a lot of puffery
it was 400 square feet
which is about the size of a one car
garage
and we launched this uh business and
we're looking at it and we didn't know
if anybody would order from us we really
didn't and in fact one of the software
engineers
looked at this little space and he said
i can't figure out whether this is
incredibly optimistic or hopelessly
pathetic
and indeed we didn't know we had no idea
whether anybody would want to buy things
in this way the business plan
called for
generating sales very slowly as
customers change their attitudes the
original business plan which i thought
was very optimistic at the time
called for amazon.com to generate 70
million dollars in sales in the year
2001.
we actually generated in excess of 3
billion in sales in the year 2001 and we
knew by the way that we were really on
to something in those first 30 days in
the first 30 days
we got
orders from all 50 states and 45
different countries with not a dollar of
advertising just all word of mouth in
the first year we didn't spend anything
on advertising all of it was word of
mouth and that really forged the company
as a that we were going to focus on
customer experience because we saw the
power of word of mouth so so very very
clearly in those early days there's
something great about
word of mouth online by the way and
feedback from customers which is that
email turns off the politeness gene in
the human being it's wonderful so people
actually tell you what they really think
uh usually in all caps
um
and uh
so
we get lots of uh info and feedback from
our customers and we try to try to use
it well there's a friend of mine who's
got a great saying about creating a
company um
which is
creating trying to build a company and
have it succeed is like eating glass and
staring into the abyss
so i mean what tends to happen is it's
sort of quite exciting for the first
several months of starting a company and
then then reality sets in things don't
go as well as planned customers aren't
signing up the technology or the product
isn't working as well as you thought
and
and then that can sometimes be
compounded by a recession
and
it can be
very very painful for several years um
so i think
um frankly starting a company
i would advise people to have a high
pain tolerance one of the first times
that i read that i demoed
recommendations live
with a live website i
um was speaking to a group of
wall street analysts
and
um and
my number one recommendation
number one personal recommendation was
the dvd called slave girls beyond
infinity
and
which was this is much less embarrassing
and you never know what you're going to
get i never know exactly what i'm going
to get because it is live and it does
change you know from minute to minute
but i'm glad to see that today i've
gotten you know apollo
and then i can see of course why was i
recommended this
because i bought cosmos and angle of
attack and another book called apollo
um so uh but slave girls beyond infinity
i'll just show you was
was a little embarrassing
um
what happened to that laser pointer
thing oh here it is
do not look directly into me okay
um there it is slave girls from beyond
infinity
let's go over here
uh this is pretty interesting um
it's uh so you can buy this dvd with a
salt of the killer bimbos
buy together
it's only 1996.
all of that product clustering is done
automatically of course
the um
you come down and you'll notice that you
know customers who bought slave girls
also bought sorority babes
in the slime ball bolo rama
and my personal favorite cannibal women
in the avocado jungle of death
and there's this interesting thing here
we um we even know when things are part
of a series so we say and also they
bought dvds from the barbarian queen
series so we can click through a quick
click through and look at the barbarian
queen and
um
there's a customer review here
uh it says for lena clarkson fans only
this is barbarian queen two this is not
even barbarian queen it's
an incredibly bad film whose only
redeeming feature is laina clarkson in
and out of some skimpy outfits she's
completely gorgeous but even she can't
save a disaster of a film you are here
with your daughter who is 21 right
and you were 21 when you became a
billionaire is that right
almost yeah all right so around that age
you were you were like the youngest
person to become a billionaire is that
right for you
yeah in terms of my own earning it on my
own yeah right okay so which is the most
important thing yeah so did you when you
were a kid did you
did you care about money or you just
cared about technology and that's it
just happened
uh mostly i love software
uh i do remember at the private school i
went to there were other kids whose
families were better off like they had a
porsche or something but it wasn't that
that big of a deal my thing was that i
just loved doing software i loved hiring
people and i was stunned when it ended
up being so valuable
really yeah you that surprised you yeah
because i always had to be careful
that we wouldn't hire too many people i
was always worried because i was people
who worked for me were older than me and
they had kids and i always thought what
if we don't get paid will i be able to
meet the payroll so i was always very
conservative
about the finances and then when we did
go uh public uh was i
uh
30 by then
uh then i was kind of stunned at what it
multiplied out to a lot of people think
that spanx started when i cut the feet
out of my pantyhose but actually it
started long before that it started when
i was selling fax machines door-to-door
and getting my car business card ripped
up in my face being escorted out of
buildings all day every day that i woke
up one day and just thought i'm in the
wrong movie like how did this happen
this is not my life cut scene director
like call the producer and i got out a
piece of paper and i wrote down what am
i good at and the only thing in the good
column was sales and i thought okay what
am i gonna do with that and i ended up
writing in my journal i'm going to
invent a product and sell it to millions
of people that will make them feel good
and then i asked the universe for an
idea and i was very specific and it took
two years and i only cut the feet out of
my pantyhose one time and i was not
going to squander any idea the universe
gave me because i had really asked for
it
and then the minute i cut the feet out i
started trying to make it i started
looking up whole manufacturers on the
internet this is before alibaba wasn't
it
yes people ask me why e-commerce so
successful in china our company alone is
much bigger than amazon
why e-commerce in china
one of the reasons why e-commerce in
china's success successful because china
had a terrible infrastructure of
commerce
right we don't have so many retail we
don't have so many like walmart kmart
everywhere
it's it's just a terrible
backward
retail system in china when internet
e-commerce come people love it so so
efficient
why china mobile phone you know grow
much faster than america america and
europe have such a great such a great
system of telephone we don't have 10 of
them
right amount like 100 family can only
have one telephone that days when mobile
come we love that we just go there so
there is a lip flop
we don't have the rules or laws most of
the government offices they don't know
how to make rules laws for internet
because nobody realizes what the
internet look like so that leave us a
chance to grow fast europe
very interesting you have such a perfect
rules loss
then everything you do let's follow the
rules a lot and everything we think
about the thing they do let's follow the
rules a lot and everything we think
about they start to worry when they're
worried they make rules lost
when we have a problems we start to
solve the problems
then think about rules and laws
you have a problem that can make rules a
loss
so
i worry about europe
i worry
i worry about the worries of the europe
if every africa does not worry asia does
not worry why europe worry about
right you don't have the solutions for
artificial intelligence oh you know
they're going to destroy a lot of things
human life
forget it
let me tell you artificial intelligence
i think
we only by using artificial intelligence
to arrest and catch a lot of thieves
my theory i told my engineers i said
now
when you love somebody you may not have
reasons
but when you
hate somebody
you have logic and reasons
we have logical reasons machine can
always do better than that
so we have a trillions of dollar
transaction on alipay every day
a lot of people want to steal the money
how can you oversee when you have like a
one billion users using that there are
so many cheatings
human being cannot do it so we teach
machines to catch all the thieves
machines never forget
no matter how smart you are one person
can create 10 ways of cheating
you are the smartest person in the world
but we teach the machine
every way everything we just discovered
from other people the machine can
remember over a hundred thousand ways of
cheating when you start the cheating
machine find you
so
one way
bad guys using artificial intelligence
doing bad things other thing we're using
artificial intelligence to catch bad
guys
so there is always in any unbalance
how you see the world if you see
technology revolution is a problem
i'm sorry to say the problem just
started
if you think it's an opportunity
opportunity just started the only thing
is
your mentality
if the mentality is about a worry you'll
worry all the time
[Applause]
by the way
all the entrepreneurs
if everything's ready
everything's perfect
why they need you
because there is worries because there's
problems because of there's no this know
that that is your opportunity that is
our opportunity and
keep on that
you believing you can do something a
little by little ten years later you'll
be different that's that's that's who we
are i always
was dancing to my own drum my parents
gave me a really long leash which was a
great gift for me growing up they let me
do whatever i wanted to do
within reason yeah and i always you know
all of us we always come against this
wall of fear you know this crazy wall of
fear and you can either go to the wall
and turn around you can go through the
wall yes and i was i always every time i
went around turned around and went back
home because i was too scared
i had crazy resentment
or crazy guilt that i wasn't able to do
it regret not resentment yeah regret
yeah and every time i went through the
wall
and got to the other side it was so
addicting and i was so proud of myself
so uh let me just give you a quick
example when i was growing up i grew up
in new york city
uh on long island in the 80s when break
dancing and rap and all this stuff was
happening yep and i was really into
break dancing i don't know i don't look
like it
but you know get some cardboard out here
man we need to do something might get
some cardboard okay
and um i decided that like i could make
more money probably if i went to
washington dc you know because the kids
in washington dc couldn't be as good as
the kids in new york we invented this
whole genre so i got my friend myron
who's my partner my sister just got her
driver's license and i convinced her to
drive us to washington dc and the whole
drive down i was having all that
self-doubt yeah you know at a young age
14 15 years old like what if the kids
are better what if no one shows up what
if we get booed what if you know what if
we go there and i stink yeah and so i
was almost talking myself out i was
building the wall of doubt up brick by
brick in my own head yeah and when we
got there we went to a little bank in uh
georgetown and we set up a boom box in a
parking lot of a bank and we hit play
and my friend started spinning on his
head and he passed it to me and a crowd
gathered around and ultimately after i
did my thing more people came i took my
hat and i passed it around and we made
about 200 i paid my sister for the gas
money and then myron and i split 82
41 each and this guy you know he's
counting up the money and he's counting
up the money and he gets all the money
and then he sprints over to me and he
gives me a bear hug and he goes jess
[Laughter]
and
what the reason why we were rich is
because on that particular trip despite
all the fear this young little kid that
was so scared
i went around that wall and i realized i
could be rewarded
and i was like i want more of that what
was called beautiful
i didn't see myself in right and so i
had this whole idea which is part of why
all the retailers were saying no in the
early years i had this idea to not just
create products that work but let me
show
models all different people every age
skin tone skin challenge gender identity
skin problem size like let me just show
real people and prove this product works
like let me go on qvc and prove it live
let me show my own rosation i just
thought if people can see people look
like them this just makes sense to me
but all the experts said it didn't so
so back to me standing there with this
investor saying i don't think people
will buy makeup from someone who looks
like you with your body and your weight
after i went in my car and cried
like it's rejection always still hurts
uh i also just remember feeling like wow
he's passing on investing in my business
on he's making a business decision
because
of exactly why i'm starting this company
like he's just as much
i don't want to call it a victim but
just as much impacted by
by the definition of beauty that's out
there and he's literally passing on
investing in my company because of it
and so it drove my deep why for like why
i was building this company
and i took that rejection as fuel for
like oh this has got to change right and
for me it was like let me build a
company
where we show all types of beauty where
it wasn't even just about selling
product it wasn't about solving my own
problems and even though i want to help
millions of women and all that the real
why was like can i shift culture and
beauty
um for every little girl out there
who's about to start doubting herself
and every grown person who still does
and so like that drive
fueled it
and
not being afraid of rejection is so huge
and it's it's really huge for women
because it prevents a lot of people from
even trying and it hurts so for me the
foundational base of
empowerment of entrepreneurship
of any kind of engagement the
foundational base of my success
of my well-being my wholeness my
everything
is knowing who i am and where i come
from
in my living room right now
is a painting that i've owned now for 30
years you can google it
it's called to the highest bidder
and it's at the center of my house
and it's at the center of my house
because it actually is symbolic of the
foundation of not the house but the
foundation for my life the painting is
by harry rosalind who was a genre
painter painter in the
early 20th late 19th century
and the painting is over six feet tall
and it shows a slave woman
on the auction block
holding her daughter's hand
and i cannot come in the door my front
door or i cannot leave without passing
that painting i am reminded of where i
come from every day of my life and i am
reminded because i never want to forget
it
and in my library
i have a framed list of enslaved
african-american people remember i
showed you
who were held in bondage on various
plantations
listed in the ledgers alongside
the cows
and the horses
and the buggies and the other property
and i pass this list every day
and often i stop in front of it and just
speak their names
out loud and their ages
jonas
11 years old 500
sarah
41 years old
900
elizabeth
57
hundred dollars
and i force myself to consider
the absurdity and the obscenity
of prices being affixed to each one
should they be placed up for sale
and i sometimes just pause before them
with a prayer
particularly before i have to make a big
decision about
one of my companies or
whether i move forward or whether i stay
still
it reminds me speaking those names out
loud
not only of where i've come from
but how far
i have to go
because of them
and it reminds me that i am never alone
it reminds me of what i've come through
to get through and everybody has a
different talent
and the reason we're all so messed up is
because you're looking at everybody
else's talent
and wishing you had some of their talent
all the energy that you spend thinking
about wishing about being jealous of
envious of anybody else is energy that
you're not only putting out is going to
come back to you negatively but you're
taking that away from you all your
energy should be forced on what do i
have to offer what do i have to give how
can i be used in service because dr
king's message of not everybody can be
famous but everybody can be great
because greatness is determined by
service and there is not a job in here
that you can do that you don't switch
the paradigm to service
and not make that job more fulfilling i
don't care what the job is if you say
i'm a singer i'm a dancer i'm an artist
i'm a teacher i'm a nurse i'm a doctor
i'm a janitor i'm a i'm a clerk but if
you say if i look at this from how do i
use this in service to something bigger
than myself
it no longer becomes a job it becomes an
offering to the world if i leave you
with nothing else it's just know this
for sure
there is not one
thing
that has ever happened to you
not one experience
not one encounter not one crisis not one
joyful thing that hasn't
happened just to make you better and
help you rise
every single thing you're calling in
whether you know it or not when you
figure out that you are calling it in
when you actually start meditating or
praying or doing or having a spiritual
practice which is the number one thing
you need if you want to be successful in
the world you need something that gives
back and nourishes you
regardless of what you call that you
need to you need to fill your cup so
that you can be so full your cup runneth
over and you have enough to give to
other people if you don't fill your cup
you end up dried up
you end up tired exhausted and don't
have enough to give to other people you
end up resentful every time somebody
asks you because your cup is empty and
now they want some of yours
so your number one job your number one
job is to fill
your cup
and make yourself whole
that's your job can you help us
understand how to cultivate how to
cultivate that
mindset of being comfortable saying no
being comfortable delegating this is
something that we found with our members
is especially difficult for young women
um and we'd love to just hear your take
on that and maybe any advice you have to
share about that i met bill
bill gates in 1991
and when i did it we had a great time
talking he thought he was going to hate
it and i i wasn't too keen on it either
and about 10 hours later we were still
talking but what really got him was when
i pulled out this little date book i'm
probably the only guy in the united
states with one of these still what oh
no i have one over there
and i just flipped through it and you
know there's there's probably nothing in
it and bill was really impressed by that
and uh
you've got to keep control of your time
and and you won't keep control of your
time unless you can say no
you can't let other people
set your agenda in life and of course
i know i'm in a very fortunate position
on that because i
i and
another way i'm not so fortunate because
more people ask me for things
and and and then they're usually friends
and they say well can't you just make
this one talk or attend this one
graduation or whatever it may be uh
you know you you've gotta you just have
to develop the ability to say no and and
and uh do it a few times uh i mean you
know the woman can't say no she's in
trouble right right
right and i mean is this something that
becomes easier over time or how did you
i don't think it's a lot easier no it
it's there's a couple there's a few
things that really just aren't
uncomfortable enough
the thing i like the thing i dislike the
most the only thing i really dislike in
connection with my job is that i have to
fire somebody i mean that does not get
easy for
the easier for me as life is going on
and saying no is not like firing people
but it's got a little bit of the same
aspect to it it's not easy to say no
particularly to a friend uh but i will
have every day
three or four or five requests to do
something and i i can't do them all you
know and uh
but i'm not promising it gets easier
but but just keep doing it right
otherwise other people will be running
your life we've got to try to create an
electric car company but it wasn't as
though in creating these companies that
we thought that we would be successful
i thought that the most likely outcome
was failure
but
but it was still worth doing even though
the odds of success were low in fact
even for for spacex the
originally what i started doing was not
creating a rocket company but but
actually was going to do
a small mission to mars which was just a
philanthropic mission where you would
send a small greenhouse with seeds and
dehydrated gel in the wood
upon landing hydrate the gel and you'd
have this cool picture of green plants
on a red background and the public tends
to respond to precedence and
superlatives so this would be the first
life on mars furthest that life's ever
traveled
and you'd have this great money shot of
green plants on the right background
there's a really face-to-spear
uh threat of death uh due to the model 3
production round
essentially the company was bleeding
money like crazy and and just
if if we didn't solve these problems in
a very short period of time we would die
uh and it was extremely difficult
to solve them how close to death did you
come we were within
single budget weeks 22 hours a day like
what how many hours working yeah so
seven days a week
sleeping in the factory
uh i worked everywhere from i worked in
the oaks in the paint shop general
assembly body shop you ever worry about
yourself imploding like it's just too
much absolutely
no one should
put this many hours into work
this is not good
and people should not work this hard i'm
not they should not do this this is very
painful
painful in what sense
uh it's because my heart's my brain
and my heart
turns
this is not recommended for anyone i
just did it because if i didn't do it
then tesla
your chances would die like one of the
most difficult choices i ever faced
uh in life was
was in 2008 um
and um
i think i had uh
like
maybe 30 million dollars left
or 30 or 41 left in 2008 i had two
choices
i could put it all into one company
and then the other company would
definitely die
um or split it
between the two companies
and but if i split it between two
companies then both might die
and when you put your
blood sweat and tears into creating
something
you're building something it's like a
child
um
and so it's like which one
am i going to let one starve to death
i can bring myself to do it so i
split the money between the two
fortunately thank goodness they both
came through if you want to make
progress in things
i think that
um
but
the best analytical framework
for
understanding the future is physics
um i'd recommend studying
the
uh
the thinking process around physics like
not just not not the equations i mean
equations certainly they're helpful but
the the the way of thinking in physics
is
it's the best framework for
understanding things that are
counterintuitive
um
and um
and you know always taking the position
that you are some degree wrong
and your goal is to be less wrong over
time
one of the biggest mistakes people
generally make and i'm guilty of it too
is wishful thinking
you know like you want something to be
true
even if it isn't true um
and so you ignore the things that
uh you ignore the real truth because of
what you want to be true
um
this is a very difficult trap to avoid
um and like i said certainly one that i
find myself in
having problems with
but if you just take that approach of
you're always to some degree wrong and
your goal is to be less wrong
and and solicit critical feedback
particularly from friends
like friends particularly friends if
somebody loves you they want the best
for you
they don't want to tell you the bad
things
so you have to ask them
okay you know and said really i really
do want to know
and then they'll tell you the general
theme i would suggest is that all trends
are overrated
and so
if you think about current uh trends in
technology uh you know
healthcare i.t software education
software
overrated
sas enterprise software really overrated
um
big data cloud computing if you hear
those words you need to think fraud you
need to run away as fast as you possibly
can um and um and the reason these
buzzwords
um tell you that something um is that
there's these buzzwords are sort of like
a tell in poker that people are bluffing
and that there's nothing that there's uh
that the business is not
undifferentiated because the buzzwords
tell you that it is one company of a
category that's undifferentiated from
the others in that category and
therefore
are symptomatic somehow of of
a lot of competition and a bad uh a bad
business idea and so you know you don't
want to be the fourth online pet food
company you don't want to be the 10th in
film solar panel company you don't want
to be the 1000th restaurant in san
francisco and so there is something
about if you can describe um what a
company is doing um very
straightforwardly by uh referencing um
uh these these buzzwords these
categories that already exist um that's
actually a sign that it's a pretty bad
uh that's that's a pretty bad idea how
would you advise people who aren't
necessarily going into a career field in
which you would make a
large base salary such as like medicine
or
something like that maybe
performing arts or music
how would you advise us to
keep up financially with the rest of the
world
well
it is true
that a market
system does not pay as well in some in
some activities as
as might seem appropriate
for the importance of those activities
the society just take teaching for
example i mean teaching does not pay
well
and what could be more important i mean
you know you've got to be as
as interested in who you're
the teachers of your children are as who
your accountant is or you know whatever
or who's winning the heavyweight title
of the world or that sort of thing but
but it doesn't it doesn't pay well and
and
it's a fundamental choice
uh whether you're going to go into
something that for many people it'd be
it'd be a fundamental choice whether
you're going to go into something you
love or something to to try and make a
lot of money i think that
generally it pays to go with what you
love and uh
i think that
it's very hard to find people
when they get to be my age
who say they're on that they've loved
what they've done all their life and
feel was very worthwhile
but they're terribly sad they made that
choice because they didn't make a lot of
money i i don't think anybody's ever
ever said that to me that they wish
they'd gone into something else where
they were uncomfortable doing it or
didn't enjoy it didn't feel very
productive but made a lot of money so i
don't i don't think you'll find
that so i would i would i would go to
work
i would go to work
in whatever turns you on it may turn out
that it'll it'll be more profitable than
than you can think but
almost everybody here will make
enough money unless they get some
terrible habits along the way
to do reasonably well and and doing
reasonably well in this country
really is
is uh is pretty darn good i mean
it is it's not necessary to have
uh huge amounts of money in order enjoy
yourself i enjoyed myself when i was at
my ten thousand dollars and i live in
the same house that i lived in when i
was making it when i had about that i
bought it 41 years ago i like the house
then i like the house now i mean
if you think about it
if you have a reasonable job
you'll be eating at mcdonald's and i'll
be eating a mcdonald's so we're we're to
push on on food i mean you know in fact
i hope it's dairy queen actually and
maybe
uh and if you come to dairy queen you'll
see me and you can order anything on the
menu i can order we both can afford it
uh
you know you'll you'll wear the same
clothes i wear i'll pay more for my
suits but as soon as i put them on they
look cheap on me so we'll look about the
same and
uh
we'll both live in the same kind of
houses i live in that house from 41
years ago and it's it's it's warm in
winter and it's cool in summer and it's
comfortable
and you'll live in a house that's that's
similar and then and what difference
does it make if you have 50 more rooms
or you know guest houses or all that
you know it'll probably just bring you
problems i mean you have to worry about
the about the greens keeper or something
when you get through so i
i i have been in the houses of people uh
where the houses are worth
[Music]
oh probably 200 times
uh what my house is worth and i would
not be any happier in those houses at
all in fact i'd be less happy i just
have one more thing to
to worry about and you know the
dozens of people around the place and
people quitting and people stealing from
you and all kinds of things to hell with
it yeah uh
we drive we'll drive the same kind of
car in fact you'll probably drive a
better car i drive a car's about eight
years old i don't know what it's worth
now but it gets me around fine i mean
i'm perfectly happy we'll watch
we'll watch the same television you know
we'll work on the same computer pretty
much the only difference will be
how we travel long distances you know i
will
fly in a plane that's
more comfortable than
than flying southwest airlines or
something and which i've got nothing
against but that's the one real big
difference and other than that i do what
i like every day i hope you you'll do
what you like every day to do and i work
with nice people i hope you work with
nice people
uh and that's there's 24 hours in the
day and those are where the hours go so
great wealth
uh
is
the tiniest bit different
in a real sense than having just a
decent
a decent income and
and to trade
a decent income
and something you love doing and
something where you feel worthwhile
doing it
for
huge wealth where you trade off a lot of
your principles
uh would be a terrible mistake yeah we
faced a lot of challenges but i'm sure
alibaba is going to face him more
challenges
we worry every day
when i was young when company was young
we thought well
what if when alibaba become
that big
my life will be easier then now the
companies that the bigger the company
the more problems i have
so
why you are still small company enjoy it
you will never experience the happiness
of operating a small company
any life we're going to be too big you
have so much headaches
so many things happening
and people say jack
you know there are a lot of books about
you but there's none of the books i
write myself if there's one book i want
to write in the future it's called
alibaba 1001 mistakes
we made so many mistakes
we had so many troubles
believing or not
china
built up e-commerce company
built up a internet related company
no internet connection at that time
no v no no credit cards
no delivery system
it's so we make we make problems all the
time
it's not easy
but we tell ourselves
we will be successful until we make ten
thousand mistakes
we will be successful
if we survive in any crisis
so when crisis came we know it's a
challenge
everybody
start to be united
we solve the challenge then we complete
each other before
we solve the problem of the crisis
we should not complain
though
i have a problem in in hr i have a
problem in financing i have a problem in
technology i have a problem everywhere
tell me so that's why i i become a
mentor in entrepreneurs uh program in
china people a lot of entrepreneurs have
crashing when i listen to their
questions oh my god i have this problem
too so
i would say
we have gone through almond almost nine
more than 90 percent of the problems
that any entrepreneur 90
of the problems that any entrepreneurs
have met this is what we feel proud
at the end of the day i'm going to tell
my kids my grandchildren
it's not the thing we feel proud we we
made alibaba
it's so many mistakes
that we overcome
so many challenges we experienced that
make me feel proud life is about
experience so when you become
entrepreneur
don't worry about the competitors
don't worry about the mistakes
don't worry about the challenges
go through it that's the great fun part
of your business of your experience and
then
you got a courage you got a wisdom you
got a team follow you you mentioned that
whilst writing 10x raw something changed
for you yeah yeah
what was that was it was that sort of
this look the next rule to going all in
or no the 10x world was it was just the
awareness of i had been dependent upon
one vertical
right and i'm sitting there looking okay
i work my ass off
uh i i was good at my craft
i saved my money
what did i do wrong here dude
51 years old
i should have
i should be like so rich right now
i got i mean i should be late not even
huh where's my jet racing i wasn't even
thinking about injecting right i wasn't
even thinking about i should just be
like
i was still having to do business with
people i didn't like
i'm like why am i still kissing asses
and i don't mind kissing asses like i
don't mind i'll do whatever it takes but
i'm like
why am i still flying three million
miles every three years like i was
banging miles down i wasn't 150 000
miles a year wow you know away from my
family like like my life was miserable
i'm like
it's fine that you do that for 20 years
it's not fine if you do it forever
and
i'm like oh my god dude i wasn't scaling
now i didn't know that until the economy
um basically served up the lesson right
all right we're going to take your three
businesses
and we're going to show you that we you
really only have like maybe
a half of one business
took took the first business and just
cut it in half took the second business
took it down to like 90
like just killed this partner i had
and the third business was real estate
and it was frozen it was literally like
they put it in a freezer and said you
can't you're not gonna lose any of this
but it's worth nothing to you today yeah
and i was a life support
and i'm like i'll never do this again i
will never be dependent upon
one vertical
one partner
or a handful of real estate i had three
real estate properties
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want seven more amazing lessons from
successful billionaires check the video
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there we got this company just about
ready to launch
and uh we're looking at it one and
looking at this little tiny fulfillment
center we were here by then in this
building we had a basement fulfillment
center